Or Matias, thank you for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
It's actually Matias, and thank you for having me.
That's debatable. Okay. So, I have the privilege of speaking to my brother now for 20 minutes.
One of the most incredibly talented musicians that I have ever met and will ever meet in my life.
A musical director of Broadway, Juilliard, NYU, for Musical Theatre. Now you are lecturing at a university
What are you doing? Give me a little bit of a rundown.
These days I'm staying home and washing my hands as I hope all of your viewers are.
But yeah, it's been quite a ride. I mean, like you mentioned I've kinda run the gamut from being in classical music
for many years to then. Working with rock bands and pop bands.
And I'm kinda finding myself at the heart of this musical theatre scene in New York.
And now have the privilege of teaching at Manhattan School of Music which has been so rewarding.
And it's been kind of a wild trajectory figuring out how to navigate all of these musical interests that I have
And kind of keeping things fresh and really trying to trust my instincts
And in terms of you know letting the road kind of take me between these various paths
and figuring out how to just learn the most from the musical legends around me I think.
Definitely. So, I mean coming from what you called the entrepreneurship world.
The paths for a computer scientist or an entrepreneur are somewhat clear you know.
You're getting to a good university. You're in Israel you go to a good unit
You start programming at an early age and then you work as a software engineer and so on and so on.
How does it work in music? So, what do you have to do to get to the level of being in Broadway?
as musician. Now as composer. And being one of the top pianists in the world.
Yeah. That's really a kind of a million-dollar question. I think it's like the first question that I get asked
by these incredibly talented young people who make their way to the city and get started
and want to know what the path is like and I think the truth is you know, there's this known
kind of phrase or adet which is you have to be at the right place at the right time.
But I think a lot of it is just like being in as many places during as many times as possible.
And I think that for me it was really making sure that I wasn't pitch and holing myself
to one very very specific either style or form of performance of kind of idea
of what I wanted to purse in front of me.
It was really just figuring out how to really finesse the thing that sounded interesting to me.
And I can be a little bit more specific. No. I grow up writing songs and being inspired by a lot of Israeli song writers
and American song writers and thinking that I wanted to be a song writer.
And So I spent my formative teenage years writing as many songs as I possibly could.
And still listen to them, yeah.
And learning from the great great song writers who I was inspired by their work.
And so I did that for many years. And then weirdly you know, when I was 16, when I was living in Palo Alto
I kind of found myself really immersed with the dream of pursuing classical music to the highest level.
So then I started practicing for hours a day and really taking that seriously.
And found myself a Juilliard. And you know did that--
Wait, back back. What does it mean for hours a day? Paint me a picture.
Because you know most people don't get to experience what I've experienced growing up.
Having a brother that's all there next to the piano that's doing scales on top of scales on top of scales.
Give me a run down. What is it like?
Yeah. So that's a great question. And it's something that I have to admit even for myself.
I came to it a little bit later than a lot of my Juilliard peers who had kind of been doing it since they were kids.
But for me you know, like a daily routine like you're saying what often consist of starting the day with an hour of scales
or technical exercises. And that's something that for me was really kind of the gateway into the practice day.
Warming up the hands and stretching the boundaries of what was possible physically at the instrument.
Working on things like dexterity. Working on things like precision.
And making sure that all the fingers were even in terms of the way they were approaching the piano.
So that's like you know, that's a very kind of methodical, technical form of practice.
And then you can really in terms of how those hours are spent, it's kind of amazing.
Because when you look at the idea of working on a piece of music,
you know there's a technical element of being able to perform it.
So if you think of even pieces that you know people have heard of like Rachmaninoff Concertos
So there's an element of being able to play the note which in of itself is an enormous task.
And it takes hundreds of hours in order to finesse but then there's also the element of the musical work.
Which is the question of exactly how you're executing each phrase.
And the emotions that you're putting into it.
Exactly. And that is endless. And it's all about the relationship between how much control you have in a technical level.
In order to be execute the ideas that you have on a musical level.
And so that's the relationship that you work on during the practice session.
But you actually you know, when you look at sports and you look at let's say soccer,
you have some of the inevitable injuries that people have throughout their career.
You have some similar injuries but from a musical perspective, right?
Yeah. I mean remember the hands and your back and everything.
Yeah, it was so the kind of the crazy twist to the kind of art that my story took is that
after all these years of really practicing and getting into Juilliard and feeling so excited.
I found myself there enjoying my freshman year, I was so eager to prove myself.
That I was practicing tenfolds and sometimes spending 12 hours a day in the practice room
And few months into my very first year, I started feeling these tingles around my right arm
And it kind of went from zero to 60 in a matter of days.
And I found myself with crippling tendonitis, and I actually had to stop playing the piano
for about six months. I went back. I was seeing this Physiotherapist
so it allows me to practice for five minutes a day. And so, there was this crazy moment
where I was in this epicenter of the greatest musical institution in the world
and everybody around me kind of leaping and strides and
I was able to touch the piano for five minutes a day so that was very very challenging.
To say it was the least period in my life.
Unbelievable. For the thousands of people who wished they could be in Juilliard
but because of their activity they don't have the opportunity to be there
Give me two sentences of what those four years were like. Both the good and the bad.
You open up a lard can of worms, my komatias.
So, the good is certainly the fact that you know I was at this institution that gave me musical tools
that I know for a certain that I would not have acquired anywhere else in the world.
I mean it's unbelievable on the amount of knowledge and technique and understanding and depth
It's something I'm drawn every day, right now, when I write for theater,
When I compose for various mediums. It's just this like amazing tool box of knowledge that I acquired
Do you know that the more challenging side of the school is the technical element
Because part of what the school does is that it preps you in such a profound way
to be able to tackle anything under any circumstance, with any level of duress
which means that the expectations are incredibly high and the demands are high
And sometimes it's possible to a little bit lose sight of the heart behind the things
that you're working on because the speed is so robust
And so I will say for me, as somebody who came to school already feeling like
I was struggling to keep up with the technical elements
It was hard for me to navigate the demands and the passion for the elements itself.
And I'm sure that with all of that you also have this huge competitive nature in any selective place
where you're competing at the end over slots.
And you know the Broadway industry, notorious for being what it is.
And then you have this incredible transition to doing your masters at NYU
And you're transitioning more to the musical theater world
which is radically different from classical music. Right?
How did that even happen?
There's a story that I tell and it sounds hyper dramatize but I swear it's true.
And we can have an alibi to the story. But the story goes that during my senior year at Juilliard
I had this incredible Theory teacher named Thomas Cabaniss who I really really admire and appreciated
And I was writing all these songs and one day you know, what I would do is sometimes
before classes or after classes, I would linger in the teacher studios to just play my songs
Because the teacher studios has the best pianos. And so, I was kind of hanging out
in Tom's classroom playing the song of mine. And after the song is over,
he comes from behind the door, and he's like, "Did you write that song?"
And I was like, "Yeah, yeah. I write a bunch of songs. That's one of them."
And he hands me a piece of paper and says something like, "Show up at this address tomorrow."
Which can be creepy but it was also quite profound.
Because the address that I ended up finding myself up was this incredible human named Mel Marvin.
who to this day has become one of my greatest mentors.
And Mel Marvin, in addition to being an unbelievable Broadway composer
and brought to music for the [--] Broadway,
And also is one of the head composers of this musical theatre writing program at NYU.
And so we were at his house and he asked me to play him a bunch of my songs
And I did. And he just turned to me and said, "Have you ever thought about writing for theater?"
And I genuinely admittedly haven’t. I mean you know, we grow up in a household in Israel
which is very cultured but musical theatre wasn't heavenly on my radar
And I said to him, "You know what? Thank you but that's not really what I do."
And he said to me, "Okay. Well, have you heard of this composer? And this composer?"
And he started playing me all of this amazing musical theatre songs.
Like Sondheim, and Adam Guettel, and Michael John LaChiusa. All these people
And he said, "This is the music that's being read and you should check it out."
And he encouraged me to apply to this program at NYU.
And at the time I was kind of toying with the idea of maybe going to LA
to do some film scoring after Juilliard etcetera, but I said to myself "Why not, I'll apply."
And he very generously offered me this full scholarship. This deans fellowship to go to NYU.
And get my master’s degree in musical theater. And I said, "You know, this sounds a great opportunity."
And while I was there, I met all of these incredible people and started music directing.
And it kinda happen serendipitously and naturally.
Unbelievable
I mean, you've been quite in few productions on both on and off Broadway.
You know I remember much younger, I watched you as you played piano at the "Rent".
And you're, I remember you're practicing for hours for the last five years
Which made me fall in love with that show. And in general, I mean
I owe it to you my love for musical theater now. And you know how much I love musical theater.
Arguably more than you do. This quite ironic I have to say.
Given that I cannot sing and I cannot play.
And I cannot dance of course. And then you went on to be a huge huge huge part
of the hugest successful show "The Great Comet".
And you've really seen it through it all. Right?
You really felt what it's like to bring a show from ideation to Broadway.
Talk to me about this really unique experience that even most people don't get to experience.
Yeah, kind of wild. Kind of wild.
So the story of my relationship with that show is kind of insane
Because, like you said, I had been kind of doing all of this, like playing piano in pits, in subbing
and Rent, and for the last five years, I'm really trying to make my name as a Music Director
And I had music directed a Reading.
And in theater speak, a Reading is basically a week long workshop.
It's 29 hours which you basically just workshop a piece to get it to a very very basic form of presentation.
And I had done this workshop for an amazing, amazing theater company called "Ars Nova"
which to this day has become kind of an artistic home to me
and I loved it and expressed to their artistic director Jason Eagan
that I wanted to be able to do more with them
and he said to me, "You know what? There's this guy who we just commissioned a piece from
and you should meet him. I think you two will hit it off because you both have
your passion about class, on jazz, on rock, and come from all this background and his name is Dave Malloy."
And so, he put me in touched with Dave. And I remembered I travelled to Brooklyn
And we ended up sitting in this coffee shop and talking about everything.
From Bach to Tom Waits, to any kind of music that you can imagine.
And Dave had just started putting together the final version of Great Comet for its original production.
And weirdly, he first invited me to come audition for one of the characters.
The Balaga, right?
The Balaga, who was at the time also an associate.
Music Director Dave was also the music director.
It wasn't enough that he was the writer, book writer, lyricist, composer, and orchestrator.
He was also the music director of the original production.
And you know, a lot of things were happening with my life at the time,
I mean, it just so happened that I got offer to go to Australia and New Zealand for a tour with this violinist.
And so, I very sadly kinda had to withdraw myself from the pool of that production.
But I was following and saw it. And it was absolutely incredible.
And I was so honored when the show got picked up by a commercial producer
and then taken on to have a commercial life, Dave called me and said, "Listen."
Oh I should also say. I've also forgot that Dave also played the lead role of "Pierre" in the production.
Right. That's correct. Yup.
And Dave said to me, "Listen, I think I'm doing one thing too many.
I'm looking for a music director Will you do it?"
And so I came. And I'm interviewed again with the team.
And I became the official music director of the show in its first commercial off-Broadway phase
which was done on 14th street, right underneath the high line.
And there was this magical magical time which I remember you came to see it
I think to receive a photo of you young in costume
Yeah, yeah. You dressed me up. I was sitting next to you. I was feeling the power.
And you know, we fast forward and you're all of a sudden
you're in the heart of Times Square on Broadway
With over a thousand people in the audience in this very interactive,
engaging production with Josh Groban as the lead actor.
And every time I still see the Good Morning America snippets of where you guys are performing.
It just puts a smile on my face. And all my friends who loves musical theater.
They just can't stop raving about the Great Comet and the work that you did there.
It was just so incredible. But you're not just a musical director.
Because you also were nominated for an award for being an actor acting as Rachmaninoff.
So funny that you're mentioning him for ad list
because you're actually playing Rachmaninoff at the Lincoln Center, right?
Yeah. So, Dave who wrote Great Comet wrote this incredible piece called "Preludes"
which was about specifically about appearing Rachmaninoff's life when he suffered from writer's block.
And I had the distinct privilege of playing. In the show there were two of us playing Rachmaninoff.
I played the pianist version of him.
And my wonderful friend Gabriel Ebert played the kind of composer troubled from host writers block.
And yeah, I had the honor of being nominated for Lucille Lortel award for that performance.
And that piece really had my heart. I love working on that so very much.
Incredible. But your true passion after all of this and with all of this,
So you've already accomplished more than the top 99.9% percentile of musicians could accomplished
Yeah, your heart lies at composition and artistically exploring your inner life
And the music that you're creating is very different.
It has a lot of right jazz to it. It has a lot of different musical styling to it.
Tell me a little bit about what is composing to you?
Yeah. So, like I mentioned, this all began with me as a kid wanting to write songs
I mean I think you know, one of the big big big sounds that was in our house growing up
and we contributed it to, I think mostly to our father who has CDs of Johnny Richter
And wonderful Israeli song writer Matti Caspi.
And those we're these two titans playing in our house. And I remember hearing their music
which is infused with, and you know for Matti Caspi is like Brazilian rhythms
and for Johnny Richter, it's American jazz. And its these amazing harmonies with soulful melodies
And that's exactly the kind of stuff that I love doing so much.
And I wanted to pursue my whole life doing. And now I'm finally, you know I'm 32,
And finally taking the time to say, "All right, I've done all that incredible work facilitating other people’s writing.
And now it's time to go back and invest in my own."
And so I wrote this musical called the "The Wave".
Which is based on this really kind of heroine experiment.
In which a teacher turned the whole high school into this facetious movement in the 60's.
And I've been developing it for a few years with my fiancée Chloe Treat.
Who I know that you also interviewed.
And we finally, finally this year are getting the world premiere production of it in Austria.
You know, knock on wood. God willing.
Well, the world tour?
So the world premiere of this musical in Linz Austria, God willing you know.
Let's just hope the worlds starts healing as quickly as possible.
That is just incredible. So, we're almost at 20 minutes.
But if I have to ask you the most important question, I need three words that best describe you.
Or as somebody that you worked with would describe you as.
Okay. Passionate.
I'd say, hardworking or diligent.
And earnest.
Earnest. Okay, explain that first.
I feel like I really believe in putting my heart out. Just being a true self.
I try to, especially in my work, to not put a facade.
When I write music, I try to let it be kind of the most honest and earnest side of me.
And sometimes just to allow myself to be vulnerable. Even if not everybody responds to it.
But to present myself in kind of the purest forms possible.
I love it. Or, akhi, todah rabah. That was amazing.
Thank you brother Michael. This was so fun. Take Care. Bye